bonsoir vous êtes réunis tous les deux
sur la scène du Théâtre de Paris pour
Momo donc 2 et avec Sébastien Thierry
mise en scène de la distillation Shola
très belle affiche vous n'avez pas vu ça
depuis les plus belles claires
alors disons le tout de suite la pièce
est d'ores et déjà un immense succès
c'est plein pour les deux prochains mois
pas besoin de faire de promo en fait on
est là pour vous faire plaisir
je pense bien
de quoi on pourrait parler la rentrée
théâtrale il y a beaucoup de chanteurs
qui montent sur scène pour cette rentrée
théâtrale Sylvie Vartan Michel Sardou
Marc Lavoine j'ai pas envie de vous
mettre à la chanson tous les deux non là
c'est fait depuis longtemps ouais
alors la pièce s'appelle Momo Momo c'est
Sébastien Thierry qui débarque donc chez
un couple en leur disant qu'il est leur
fils et ce qui est dingue c'est que tout
le prouve en fait on y croit le mec qui
débarque comme ça c'est des parents en
disant je suis votre enfant s'est
inspiré de la vie d'Albert de Monaco
vous croyez
alors c'est l'histoire d'un enfant qui
reconnais ses parents et pas l'inverse
vous êtes époustouflant tous les deux
vraiment
sans doute en voyant cette pièce on a un
peu le choc que devait avoir les gens à
l'époque en voyant fedo et la biche il y
a cette rapidité cette folie etc c'est
populaire et populaire c'est la plus
populaire de ces pièces en fait
alors Muriel Sébastien écrit cette pièce
pour vous
il aurait pu appeler ça Mumu
un côté brutal et en même temps une
sensibilité c'est pile l'actrice pour
jouer mes phrases
pour moi c'est là où c'est
extraordinaire c'est bon on sait que
vous savez faire rire mais là vous êtes
un certain moment comme ça vous êtes
pris une histoire fait que moi elle
bascule elle est un peu les traîtres
troublée elle va ça vient mieux les
choses en elle mais vous vous avez eu
vous avez été enceinte à un moment vous
avez perdu l'enfant donc ça ça rejoint
quand même des choses très personnelles
j'imagine c'était un accident c'était
pas c'était pas c'était pas une volonté
non moi j'étais tellement pas au poids
j'avais un tel travail à faire sur moi
j'avais tellement
j'étais mon propre enfant quoi il a
fallu d'abord que je règle tellement de
choses et quand j'ai réglé c'était trop
tard vous pensez pas Muriel que l'enfant
aurait pu vous sauver la vie finalement
je le dis c'est souvent les enfants et
je reprochais entre guillemets parce que
j'en voulais un peu à la terre entière
pendant pas mal de temps parce que dans
ma souffrance mais je disais ces femmes
qui disaient mais moi je vais faire un
enfant pour moi il va me sauver je
trouvais ça dégueulasse et en même temps
elles avaient fait 13 ans parce que ça
met plus d'un coup peut-être moi qui va
être tel problème avec la réalité j'en
saurais peine vous aurez ramené sur
terre ça c'est sûr et alors aujourd'hui
vous arrivez à vivre avec tous vos
regrets parce que vous avez beaucoup de
regrets c'est incroyable ça il y a votre
mère vous dites je suis passé à côté de
ma relation avec elle est obligé de
regretter ça parce que
non on n'est pas obligé de regretter
parce que ma mère si je pouvais lui
parler je dirais je suis désolé je pense
qu'elle aussi est désolée on a fait
comme on l'a pu avec qui on était et
comme voilà il y a un regret du cinéma
ça c'est quand même un truc une
tristesse mais on ne demande pas proposé
quoi du tout
c'est très prétent
l'actrice
vous avez déclaré je me suis fait
refaire les dents je suis faire faire
les seins j'ai perdu du poids vous êtes
vraiment essayé
comédienne elle est rentré au premier au
Conservatoire ça suffisait j'ai pas fait
tout ça pour faire du cinéma ça c'était
normal parce que j'ai pas j'ai pas
Sharon Stone en sortant dessus tout de
suite donc je voyais je fais tout pour
mon approcher ma foi j'ai encore du
boulot mais c'est commencer par les
dents et les seins très bien
alors François quand Sébastien Thierry
vous a fait lire la pièce c'était juste
avant les répétitions de deux hommes
tout nus c'est pas d'hier
sur l'histoire cette histoire de type
qui débarque un jour en vous disant
qu'il est votre fils en même temps vous
avec toutes vos tournées théâtrales en
province ça doit vous arriver souvent
qu'un mec débarque en disant papa oui
oui
papa et alors vous Muriel ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que vous avez été
fasciné par l'idée de de jouer avec
quelqu'un qui avait appelé à voter
François Bayrou
François on va pas parler de vos trois
albums je crois qu'on en a beaucoup
parlé on va parler de votre livre qui
s'appelle mille et une manières de poser
sa main sous le manteau quand on fait
une photo et c'est vraiment c'est
extraordinaire
vous vous donnez vraiment des conseils
dans ce bouquin
la perfection incroyable
je pensais que vous aviez arrêté vos
conneries de mixer sociale non non non
5000 bouteilles de vin dans la cave
j'ai toujours au casino avenue Jean
Lolive absolument faites vos courses
là-bas je vais très simplement en fait
je joue toujours le 24
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu